yes I for screen junkies boobie bytes
hello everybody I was tipping my cap to
you the viewers at home welcome to movie
fights
I'm your host this week dan merle how
Rudnik is on assignment he's actually
overseas working on something for us
that we're super excited to show you and
share with you so I will be your host
today on movie fights is a marvelous
movie fight but I want to say first up
first right off the bat don't worry
there will be no questions about
Avengers in game there will be no
spoilers about Avengers in game we know
that most of you haven't seen it yet we
know a big chunk of our audience isn't
watching us live right now because
you're in the theater right now watching
in game we are gonna talk about in game
probably on next week's movie fights or
the week after when everybody's seen it
so while this is a Marvel themed fight
this is not to do with in game at all
no spoiling will happen here on the show
we're just here to have fun and get
everybody pumped if they're not already
at the theaters watching Avengers and we
have a fantastic panel to join us first
of all he's a friend of the show you've
seen him here before and he will be in a
movie this summer called spider-man far
from home is that this pronunciation
correct yes follow me thank you
welcome back Tony we have a Laurie hi
Tony not only are you gracing us with
your presence here on movie fights you
also wrote a great article that's on
phantom comm right now taking us through
your journey to being Flash Thompson in
the MCU absolutely do you want to just
like tell people what they what they're
gonna read there yeah I mean I had a fun
time writing it and I really appreciate
you guys giving me the opportunity to
put it out there so thank you you guys
and it's just basically my journey as a
small child immersed in the world of
Marvel and into me actually joining the
MCU and it's got a lot of fun and
tear-jerking stories in there that is it
like there's some really generally
amazing stuff in there you can check
that out right now it's on phantom
column there's links in the description
it's a great read Tony thank you for
joining us thank you for having me
competing against Tony we have rich also
returning to the show
he is the host of the meaning of podcast
ace Cabrera hey back are you here thanks
good good every time I come back I
always say I'm gonna win and everyone
but uh one of these days our window
today knows but uh but yeah that's what
I'm hoping for and last but certainly
not least she is one member of the
sketch team night church you've seen her
on the El Rey Network also a friend of
the show also coming back Vanessa
Griffin Vanessa welcome I'm super
psyched to be back yeah so this is all
Marvel all MCU related and keeping our
facts straight to make sure that we
don't go too far off the rails within
reason a lot the return of lawn Dan
calling the professor lawn Harris he'll
be checking the facts he will also be
giving us his opinion on each round and
of course the voice of the people
Danielle Radford thank you how's
anything over there first thing we got
to talk about the people we love y'all
we are we love how enthusiastic you are
we tried man but we are shutting down
the chat air people are not being cool
most of them are probably not our
audience people are not being chilled so
there is not gonna be a chat for this
sorry guys sometimes the the bad app
will spoil it for the rest of the bunch
the chat lasted two minutes it's like
the end of space invaders were there all
just happen at you and I only got so
many fingers so well so the way that
it'll work is unfortunately we can't do
the chat because for the people who are
it I just dropped my pen
there will be no pen in this episode
the way that this will work is at the
end of every round I will give my
opinion lon will give his an opinion his
opinion if there's a consensus then the
point will go to that person however if
we need to break a tie then we will go
to Daniel Radford Daniel you are the
voice of the people tell them how that's
going to work okay so how this is going
to work is that there is a pull the pole
is going to be up in your top right
corner there's a whole thing in the
description um if you have any questions
about how that works you can check the
description and that will give you your
answers the pull options do not come up
until everyone has presented their
initial arguments because we want this
to be about the actual arguments and so
the pole will be up for all of them but
the only time it counts is if there's
some kind of like tie we can't figure
out who's doing what and then that is
when we shall turn to you the viewers
and you can give us your input then
thank you very much Danielle and as a
reminder to our players this is a
best-of-seven total game you need four
points to win we'll have three regular
rounds following that we will have a
speed round that could be up to four
questions in the event of a one 1-1 tie
or somebody goes on a run and has a
three to nothing lead and we have to
figure out who else goes to the speed
round lab a tie-break around that point
won't count but it will put you through
to the final round gotcha any questions
are you ready to do this yeah let's do
it
Thank You Thor yeah that's a hell
rudnick tradition I can't broke that one
round one we have in this MC you fight
of course the culmination of the MCU
that we've seen so far in theaters
starting tonight and tomorrow but we
wanted to know looking back at the 21
films that have come before it what is
the best scene from any movie in the MCU
the Marvel Cinematic Universe from Iron
Man back in 2008 to to Captain Marvel
which opened earlier this year what is
the best scene from any MCU movie and
we're gonna go to Tony revelry first so
I chose Iron Man 1 the closing scene of
that movie where are you sup on a press
conference he's trying to deny and he
just gives up and says I am Iron Man
that's what I'm picking I'll let you
guys all right yeah let's see yeah I
could just give their pick real quick
and then we'll get in the debate what do
you think sure I picked my favorite
scene from my favorite Marvel movie and
what I consider to be the perfect
culmination of a Marvel movie and that
is guardians of the galaxy when Peter
Coyle holds the stone and then all the
guardians hold the stone in order to
defeat Ronan the accuser the fall of
Ronan the accuser and Vanessa what did
you pick I picked my favorite scene that
I can't even think about without smiling
and that is the scene in Thor Ragnarok
where we have a Bruce Banner and Thor
and Valkyrie together talking with Loki
tied up and Thor is retelling a story
about how Loki turned into a snake and
he picked him up because he admired
snakes and then he turned back into a
human went bad and stabbed him all right
so a fight between brothers a fight
between the intergalactic beings and a
fight between Tony Stark and himself
really guys fight it up his ego I mean I
guess I'll start I feel like I really
enjoyed your guys's picks by the way
like I thought Ragnarok is one of my
favorites in Iron Man that's an iconic
scene but I feel like they're more small
moments in small lines yours is a quick
joke yours is a iconic line but I feel
like
my scene the one I picked from guardians
of the galaxy has that range of emotions
that we know from a Marvel movie what we
want to see in a Marvel movie as that
perfect combination between heart and
humor and no scene does that as great as
Peter quill challenging ronan to a
dance-off in the middle of his you know
monologue villain type monologue trying
to destroy his and our challenges him to
a dance-off so we get that quick humor
and then all of a sudden it turns into a
very deeply emotional scene when he
thinks about to his mother dying of
cancer and he never took her hand so
when he sees Gamora trying to take his
hand he remembers that as like I'm now
saying goodbye to my mother so he takes
her hand and in reality it's all the
guardians coming together in a true
moment where they're dispersing the
power of the Infinity stone and and in a
comes full circle for the theme of the
movie which is basically like this band
of misfits coming together to face up
against this you know evil that is Ronan
the accuser because Ronan wants to
essentially destroy a people because of
his bigotry and because of his racism so
we have this group of misfits with
different backgrounds and cultures
literally coming together and
controlling the most powerful substance
in the world to me that that's that's
Marvel to the T that's the best thing we
can get from I think it's really easy to
write off this scene it's just like a
quick joke and then that's it but first
of all it was so funny that when I
bought the actual like blu-ray I
rewinded it over and over and over again
because I don't think anything made me
laugh that year as hard as that did but
also when you look at that scene on its
own it can only exist through the
culmination of seeing all of these MCU
movies come together and we know these
relationships and we know these
characters and we're so excited to see
them interact with each other it's not
just setting up origin which you know is
fantastic but already happened it's
everything that led up to this moment
it's everything that led up to us
knowing the relationship between Thor
and Loki and and Banner just kind of
coming in like the the just just tuning
in after having been hold for so long
and if you look at the actual like
behind the scenes moment of that and
just how fantastic it is that's an
improvised scene that's a fully
improvised scene and that's because
Chris Hemsworth has been Thor for so
long he knows how to be Thor and with
Tyga directing him he was able to be
Thor in a way that
humorous without being cheesy and
ham-fisted and embody it in a way that
we know that character to be it was fun
and it was something that only happens
when you have really good writing and
directing but also trusting your talent
to be the characters that they embody
and that scene is such a perfect little
example of all of that coming together
right
what I think makes my scene the best
scene in the MCU is it really sets up
everything you know you talk about all
these movies but this is a moment that
set everything up this is the iconic
moment you say but it's it's not just
iconic it's the moment in superhero
movies they always have their secret
identity and I always goes a certain way
this was the first time they bucked that
tradition and for them to do it on their
first MCU movie not only do you have a
pitch-perfect Robert Downey jr. playing
Tony Stark
you have him trying to figure out how
he's gonna you know lie to the audience
to the press that he's talking to and
he's got all these things and eventually
he says no I'm I'm this is who I am and
that's me and and you don't see that
with any superhero ever everyone's got
their secret identity no one and it
really set up the the entire MCU in its
totality from the next couple of movies
with Captain America and Thor even
coming down to earth it's like they all
knew because he set it all up for them
and I think that's what makes that
moment the best scene and and and I will
say like so many people it's so far in
the past it's 11 years ago that movie
came out yet it's still iconic to this
day and you have even I think one of the
Russo brothers were saying it's their
favorite moment in the entire MCU and
that's that's it's that for a reason
because this moment was so important for
the entire MCU well and I will say I
really like that you're seeing where you
know it's like and then I stabbed
but I think it is a bit of a throwaway
Gaghan yes they've been these characters
for so long but you had Iron Man just in
one movie and you immediately knew who
he was Robert Downey jr. was Tony Stark
he didn't needed three movies and a
perfect director he had that first
chance and he nailed it on that first
chance that moment was so Tony Stark and
Robert Downey jr. that it it just worked
and as for what you're saying in the
circular of your film having that moment
it is a great scene I think it shows a
lot of character growth in those quick
moments but I don't think it really had
the longevity that we think like i
picking a guardians of the galaxy movie
i would have rather picked group dancing
because that shows them as a family now
together I would have picked something
from guardians to maybe the Mary Poppins
scene or something like that because
that shows that growth of the characters
more than then them holding a stone
which effectively became kind of
pointless after the eventual movies yeah
when I think of best scene III think of
what an audience is trying to get out of
a scene right with your audience it's
probably one of the funniest scenes in
Thor Ragnarok and that's saying
something with yours it's probably the
most shocking scene in the MCU with mine
I really do feel like it is that full
range of what a Marvel movie can do it's
that immediate like shock of like oh my
god he's dancing against this evil
villain who's trying to destroy an
entire race of people that's that's so
like jarring humor that it makes you
laugh out loud right away and then
immediately went in turns into like oh
no he's trying to hold infinity so and
you realize that full power and then
when they come together it's that full
thematic level of like this is a family
through it all like different
backgrounds different cultures all these
people have been fighting throughout
this entire movie but they can't come
together and actually be the guardians
of the galaxy regardless of how powerful
they are individually together they're
powerful enough to be an extraordinary
being on the level of a fan owes just
these you know five
misfits bat to me is a bigger thematic
key to get something from the best scene
of an MCU movie more than either a joke
or just like a shock like well he
thought he said it or like well that was
hysterical to me it's all about emotions
and range of emotions and that's a great
if you want to throw anything about that
versus the other two scenes but also
those I can think that was a pretty good
final thought if you wanted to throw
anything else in then we'll go to
Vanessa and Tony again anything else
yeah to me that that's essentially what
what a Marvel movie is right it's that
perfect balance between heart and humor
and that's what I'd love to see and like
you said like this is the Guardians
coming together and I really do feel
like there is better moments in Iron Man
I love the scene when he breaks out of
the cave I think that might be in a
better moment but but for me this this
group of different individuals the
guardians themes that we see in this
movie the first guardians of the galaxy
are the themes we're seeing now an end
game and infinity war the themes of all
these different people coming together
different power sets different
backgrounds to defeat a bigger evil and
in this case it was Ronan which again
represents the bigotry and represents
the racism and in this case it's gonna
be found within game and with infinity
war whatever but that's the theme of it
people from different cultures coming
together to be a family
Vanessa anything you want to add not you
know not just why your seems great but
against there are two scenes and any
final thoughts that you want to throw in
yeah I would say when you mentioned that
you would paint group dancing as another
moment instead of the one he picked I
think that automatically destroys the
argument that a throwaway joke can't be
iconic because that got made into merch
that was a moment that everybody talked
about a joke being a joke just because
it's funny might I feel like people have
a tendency to consider comedy lowbrow
and therefore can't be an iconic moment
but it absolutely can and dancing Groot
is an example of that and especially
with this case like you there's the
argument to be made like yes the iron I
am Iron Man things started it but also
there's so many other moments like that
that happened earlier like we can go as
far back as the Sam Raimi spider-man's
in terms of first seeing that come to
life or we can even swap that for the
first appearance of Nick Fury knowing
that that's when the Avengers were gonna
happen not even so much I am Iron Man
but that being the thing that sets it
into motion and in this case it is the
distilled love for these
Jers on screen in one moment we have a
fleshed-out birth Bruce Banner
we have Valkyrie who's playing a kind of
character I never thought I'd seen a
million years which is essentially the
kind of unlovable drunk near do all that
I only seen a han Solo and I'm seeing
Tessa Thompson be it and in this case
we're seeing the culmination of Hulk and
Loki's relationship from the beginning
of Avengers where he was the big evil
bad - now this person that's been tied
up and it's it's the fever pitch of our
relationship with these characters all
at once and even if it's a funny moment
it's a funny moment that can only happen
after having the opportunity to get to
know these people awesome
yeah and tell any anything to say about
your scene as opposed to these two in
any final thoughts that you've got in
for Thor Ragnarok I think there were I
think that moment is really funny but
honestly I had not remembered it till
you brought it up and I think there's
way funnier moments that show and depict
their relationship like the let's do get
help like that moment in the elevator
and then coming out and then him
realizing he's going to turn on him that
moment shows their relationship more
than anything and shows the characters
growth from Thor realizing my brother's
never going to change you know and this
is who he is and I've learned but I
still love him as for why my see the
thing is you guys are talking about this
moment being just this moment but you
don't realize how impactful it has been
throughout the entire MCU Paul Bettany
says in our vision says in civil war the
uptick of superheroes and villains who
come into this world happened or tripled
or something like that since you said I
am Iron Man how important that moment
was even though we know Captain Marvel
Kane was was there in the past that's
still that was a moment that turned the
world upside down changing our reality
into this MCU we know there's there's
even Thanos in infinity war he doesn't
care about anybody in that movie but he
knows Tony Stark why does he know him
because that's the
person how important he is for the MCU
and that moment of him saying I am Iron
Man not hiding who he is is so kind of
systemic to these MCU movies and it's
it's it's there throughout the entirety
of it you know his humor that you said
balancing humor and heart he's the one
who started that by making jokes in the
middle of battle and then going into a
serious moment that was his thing so if
anything you owe it to that first movie
and that moment that started at all that
change of different things so those are
my final pots all right there we go and
that's it for round 1 line before you
get to the rulings any factual things
you need to clear up any I didn't pick
up on a single incorrect fact I think I
was all right that's the point and we
move on yeah I think everybody you all
obviously loved your moments and it was
really for me as I'm looking at it more
of going to what the question is you
know the best scene from any MCU movie
and I think you all made great arguments
for different aspects of it like Vanessa
I think you made a great argument for
why you're suppose maybe the best
character a moment in any movie Tony you
made I think a good argument for why
yours was perhaps the most important
moment ever seen in the movie but I felt
like ace for me made the case as far as
taking it outside of you know it's a
great moment but also it is this
microcosm of the MCU of the fact that
this is a band of outsiders that it does
in a lot of way encapsulate so much of
what the movies are about ultimately
that was the difference for me and so my
vote goes to ace but I'm not the only
one voting here one what would you think
yeah I'm inclined to agree with you I
thought Vanessa did a great job of sort
of selling that a comedic moment could
also be an iconic really memorable
moment I love that joke and thor
ragnarok and i thought that tony did a
really good job of sort of setting up
here's why this one moment from Iron Man
sort of birth to be MCU but the question
was what's the best scene and a sort of
really for me talked about why that
moment in that move
was so great and had so much resonance
for him so yeah I think I'd go with ace
as well all right you get the point
Danielle we didn't have to go to you for
a tiebreaker but what did the people say
that we can share and then angry well as
of right now this second at 59% was the
I am Iron Man seem 29% for a guardian
share Power Stone 11% for Thor Loki
snake scene again for those of you who
are just tuning in hi good to see you
no there is no chat today because people
were being very mean to you guys and we
can see you to be our friends and we
don't think people are mean nor friends
yes it's the the chat is only as good as
the people inside of it and today there
are some people that just wanted to
spoil a good time for everybody so sorry
but the chat will be back next week so
ace moves up we go on to round 2 ace as
a 1o we move into round 2 we've seen as
the movies have gone on through Civil
War through even Ragnarok and obviously
with infinity war last year more and
more super-powered characters joining up
and joining the Avengers we wanted to
know for round 2 what MCU character who
has no super powers no powers just a
regular Terran human should join The
Avengers so not just not just team up
with the Avengers should be an Avenger
this is round 2 hey I think I might have
started with you last time I skipped the
order so Vanessa I'll start with you
this time and then Tony I'll start with
you in round 3 so Vanessa who would you
who is your choice well go choices first
and then we'll do the are you cool I'm
gonna go with my deeply underrated girl
Maria hill Maria hill Cobie Smulders I'm
going with Ned Leeds Ned Leeds yeah the
character that you obviously know a SuJu
pick I picked what I considered to be
the best one and that's Cherie Cherie
yep trying to break up the early Tony
and Maurice in science Bros what sad
let's let's let's get some new blood
into the side good so we got Maria hill
we have Cherie
we have Ned Leeds Vanessa tell us about
Maria hill
Maria would have the least amount of
transition time of this whole panel
because she's been working with these
people forever
she knows what their communication style
is like she knows how to talk to Captain
America when she's initially briefing
him on a Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
and she gave him that whole amount of
jargon and he had no idea she knew that
she needed to boil it down to he's fast
she's weird she knows how everyone
receives information in the Avengers you
know when everybody was just bickering
amongst each other she knew that she
just needed to give everyone at task
there's a reason she's been at the right
hand of Nick Fury this whole time and
that's because she handles things in
Winter Soldier in one of those like oh
no what are we gonna do moments when
skirt
Black Widow is bleeding out in a van who
snuck in and managed to slip in
undetected as one of the agents my girl
Maria and not just that she's not really
scared or intimidated by the rest of
Avengers whereas I see Ned may be just
kind of like already just knowing
spider-man is so much for him I can't
imagine him being on the Avengers and
handling it and in the case of Maria
Hill you know she's she's fine with
talking smack to any of these people she
does it to everyone
and she's very capable like she's a well
the first moment we see her she's thrown
into action when she recognizes
something is amiss with Loki she's
Keaton she's trained she knows all of
this it would basically just be a
lateral move for her she should have
been in it by this point Maria hill
lateral move sliding right into the
Avengers ace
yes about Shuri I mean speaking of
talking smack someone who does not have
any shame or does not care who she's
talking smack to regardless of the fact
that it's the king of Wakanda and she
doesn't give a crap she literally flips
him off and black panther plus when I
think of the best person without
superpowers who can give the biggest
contribution to the Avengers and who
would be the best asset to the Avengers
who better than the smartest character
in the MCU and that's sharee from
Wakanda and I really do feel like it's
not only her charm it's not only her
intelligence but it's her contribution
to the team her skills with
computers with mechanics with building
technology with progress cuz that's a
big key and her character is progress I
feel like that is the biggest key to
help the Avengers complete whatever
mission they need we've seen in James
Bond movies we see Q we see other
characters who who are the people behind
the monitor behind the computer who give
these technological technological
advancements and tools to these
superheroes in order to complete their
mission who better than someone who is
smarter than Bruce Banner is probably
maybe smarter than Tony Stark
the fact that we can have someone like
Tony Stark who essentially kick-started
this universe and he doesn't have any
superpowers and he's you know
essentially the leader of the Avengers
you know and now we have someone like a
Sheree who can fit that role as well as
Tony Stark like that to me is like if
you have someone on par with a Tony
Stark when it comes to intelligence and
technology that's why sure he's the best
bet we have two big arguments for
experience Tony tell us about Ned leaves
why is he the right choice for the
newest Avenger well I'll tell you why
he's the right choice
somatically story wise and I'll tell you
why he's the right choice in general
character wise because Ned is a fan of
these guys these are what he's grown up
with and how great would it be to have
someone join the Avengers who is I mean
we already had so much fun seeing Tony
Knight spider-man Peter into becoming an
Avenger and he's obviously been in it
what we also like you were saying we
don't have is that Q is that guy in the
chair there's no one there like the dude
from Kim Possible is always on the you
know he doesn't need to be out in the
front fields but mind you ned is one of
the smartest people on this MCU as well
he hacked into Tony Stark's technology a
suit that Tony Stark made himself within
seconds so arguing that he is just as
smart or capable of becoming as smart as
the signs
and shuri I think it would just be a fun
dynamic to have someone young like him
who is a fan of these guys learning how
to interact with them and as well as we
the fans can now see someone who how we
would react meeting you know Tony Stark
cap and holding the shield and doing
these stuff as for why Maria Maria Hill
I think is a I think she's great but I
think she's a boring choice because we
already have Black Widow Black Widow is
essentially a better version of Maria
Hill so we don't need to have another
black widow in this Avengers team and
she works better as a right-hand man
going off to do her own things in in the
shadow of Nick Fury who is he
technically an Avenger or is he the
director of an Avenger but he sort of
started his point yeah leads the way to
the shore so I feel like she would be
more suited for a role like that like
you were saying giving tats not being an
Avenger but maybe giving tasks which I
don't think would be making that an
Avenger would be so much fun for him the
character everyone around he can learn
just as much there's potential growth in
him as opposed to Shuri
she's already just as smart she can go
off and do her own things I would love
to see her make her own team whether
that be I don't know a new Young
Avengers or something like that I would
love to see her do something like that
as opposed to she doesn't need to be in
the shadow of the science pros while you
can have someone like Ned learning from
these people constantly evolving and
growing considering she dropped the
hilarious line hey Steve that's a bad
language word she can rip with the best
of them and she's not a boring version
of Black Widow black widows got her gun
thing going on Maria is through and
through not just an agent but an
operator and somebody that very much
works for herself if you look at her
character an agents of shield not only
is she hilarious but she's a badass
when FBI agents came to arrest her her
response was why are you late if you
were my agents I would have fired you
she's not just a task
signer she's a doer and what the team
needs is a doer if the team star learn
has proved has enough Mavericks they
don't need more Mavericks they need
someone like Maria Hill and that is
great but we already have a fanboy with
spider-man we already have the
Youngblood we already have Peter and
when it comes to Sheree she needs to
stay back in Wakanda like she needs to
she needs to rule an entire country
she's got an entire people depending on
her and with Black Panther being in the
Avengers taking another person away from
being able to rule wouldn't be the
smartest move also she's young and
another hothead again we don't need
hotheads we need doers I actually want
to counter that because I really do feel
like one of the biggest themes of Black
Panther if not the biggest theme of that
entire movie is let's get out of work on
debt and help the rest of the world help
the rest of the universe who better to
do that and represent what Conda then
someone who is not the king of Wakanda
who was you know the sister of the
completely unlike her Cherie and I feel
like everything you said about Ned is
spot-on and she can do that times 10
she's um you know you're right net is
very smart but sure he is smarter and
she can pull an infinity stone out of a
you know Android created by Bruce Banner
she would have and also her youth what's
what's great about Black Panther is and
we see her her youthfulness her charm
her her idea with social media with all
these kind of jokes that she can bring
into the MCU and kind of be that
representative for a younger audience
like if I'm a 14 15 year-old watching
this New Avengers movie or watching a
new movie that's coming out later in the
future who better than Sheree to give me
that POV of like a young person who's
given us references from like Twitter
and social media and who's talking about
new technology and all that's so old and
we need this
that's Sheree to me and I feel like her
contributions would be bigger I to be
honest I love Maria Hill yeah she was
gonna be one of my choices
however Maria Hale is a dope six man
like she's coming off the bench
I feel like Sheree is like right there
point guard distributing the pass giving
everyone their due telling everyone what
to do being that cue behind the scenes
and letting everyone know how powerful
technology can help them in their
mission I agree but I think to counter
your point which is she can riff with
the Avengers
you've had med with amazing comedic
moments with him turning around in the
chair saying I'm watching porn which
means he can be as funny and lie he can
riff with them and has talked with happy
hogan so he's used to it and yes we have
a fanboy in Peter Parker with spider-man
but now he's comfortable we've seen that
in infinity war we've seen him get used
to these people and how funny would it
be to have two people fanboying as
opposed to just one shuri is great but
again I still think she'd be a better
leader of something else and your points
with with you know all the other things
you've made I think again like you said
she needs to get out of Wakanda so she
needs to get out of Wakanda and do her
own thing she doesn't need to be
attached to the Avengers while having
ned being attached to the avengers
playing that back guy role you know
calling shots from outside seeing him
develop and you know there's just a lot
there that he can have as well as would
be the first asian avenger which is
great and a nice push for for diversity
which we haven't seen and of course
we've already had black panther as an
Avenger so we already have like that and
it's I think it's very important for
different ethnicities and minorities to
see themselves be represented anything
who better than then someone like this
that's good so I'm gonna use those as
your closing thoughts okay so I'll go to
you and then Vanessa will go to you for
rebuttal and closings yeah when I feel
someone who doesn't have superpowers I
want to see a contribution to the
Avengers a team that's created of
literally gods and you know powerful
creatures of the universe I want to see
someone who can keep up with them and
that the only one on this table that
that is that is Cherie Cherie is the one
person who can keep up with someone as
intelligent as a Tony Stark and as I
said before if Tony Stark is who we
think of as when we first think of the
Avengers someone like a Shuri who's a
master of Technology master of
intelligence in order to be that kind of
q role is an incredible factor and also
on top of that she also happens to be
played by the incredible Leticia Wright
who's a BAFTA Rising Star winner
so her she essentially stole that movie
for most people who saw Black Panther
everyone was like wow Sheree is the best
care
in this movie who better than to be a
part of the Avengers than someone who is
younger who also has a different
background than most people in the
Avengers and who's probably the smartest
one and can contribute the most awesome
and Vanessa bringing home Maria Hill
first of all show me any teenager that's
good any teenage boy that's going to be
articulate in a room standing next to
Scarlett Johansson secondly it's kind of
hard to trust somebody to take over a
lot of the insane tech that happens when
you probably don't have a driver's
license cuz again he's a teenager and he
lives in New York also out of all of
these people Maria Hill has saved the
Avengers on multiple occasions she's
given them information that they haven't
had access to over been several steps
ahead of them not only that but surely
we have some very intense family
connections that could be manipulated by
an enemy and the NED he's a teenage boy
he's a soft teenage boy whose family
connections can also be incredible and
if you still look at a teenage boy wrong
they crumble I have four brothers and at
age 12 if you put any of them in front
of a magician show as a volunteer dead
and in this case we have someone who is
on flappable and also we don't really
know a lot about her family so she
doesn't have connections I could be
manipulated alright and that is time wow
I'm glad I have a fact check as I need a
second to think about this al on any
effects that you can give mates at
slashed all four times some facts we the
question was raised is Nick Fury
technically a member of the Avengers I
could not get a very clear opinion but
the Internet is leaning towards no he's
the director former director of shield
he's a founder of the Avengers but not a
official member of the team but of
course we can't be certain they don't do
like a team role call or anything that
we could use to be definitive also the
ten-year-old genius who helps Kim
Possible his name is Wade I don't think
we should use this to you know
how you won argument over the other but
Asian Avengers were mentioned we will
get shang-chi it's been confirmed
there will be an age of adventures
sometime in the next few years mm-hmm
here we go
yes string cheese thank you here's what
it here's what happened after all of
your opening arguments sequentially I
you all had the lead like every single
one of you like after your opening
argument looks like okay I was like no
okay it's like oh no I was like
everybody made such a great case for who
they listen to the counter-arguments are
trying to figure out and and sort out
everything and what when it came down to
is the ones that resonated with me the
most were I found myself agreeing
somewhat with the argument that net is
awesome but we do we do sort of have a
new person that is embedded in the
Avengers we've seen that role was played
with Peter Parker and so I had to
eliminate that so this between Sheree
and Maria Hill and I actually think that
Sheree was actually taken down and I
really liked the idea of the whole the
whole thematically a lot of the thing
about Black Panther was of leaving
Wakanda but also the idea that like
Sheree is so capable and and is kind of
a duplicate or better than so many the
Avengers they would almost be better for
her to go do her own thing and not
necessarily join The Avengers she's more
than capable of forming a new team or
something else I thought that was a
great counter and I loved Vanessa's
arguments about the transition time the
integration the fact that she has
undercover skills they they they are
they don't need any more Mavericks they
need someone whose business who can go
in there who can do it and then I
thought the take down on that was great
okay I also felt like the only major
counter that was made against Murray
Hill largely was that people thought she
was kind of better coming off the bench
which I agree is an argument but I felt
in in context of all the other arguments
that had been given that that was
probably the weakest hit against Maria
Hill so my vote goes to Vanessa and
Maria Hill long what are your thoughts
once again
you and I are lined up I thought all
three me these are all pretty characters
they're all great performances for the
actors it was hard to choose just based
on that but yeah I thought Vanessa
especially towards the end came back
really strong against all of the Maria
who countersigned they just made the
case that she's already been such an
integral part of this team she's already
contributed so much she saved them on
several times it's a natural fit for her
to join The Avengers so yeah I go
Vanessa there we go so the point goes to
Vanessa one one ace and Vanessa both
have a point Danielle before we move on
to Round three what's one of the people
say well the people with 55% of the
votes
the people were going with Cherie five
percent of the vote for from Maria Hill
19% of the vote from Nedley I also think
everyone could use a man in the chair I
totally get it thank you so much we got
ten men in the jury we call it a lot of
people a lot of people really want
Louise format man also circle I was
circling that for like an hour
like a team archivist or historian yes
the obvious that's true someone to keep
an oral history of the answers now would
be nice all right
so going into round three it is ace one
Vanessa one Tony you need this point two
to go to the tiebreaker round to go into
the speed round if either a servant wins
then the two of you will be going on to
the speed round but good news Tony
because everyone is pretty much on equal
ground because round three is a blind
fight that's right blind fight which
means that none of the
panners know what this question is
nothing competitors know what their
choices will be so here's how it's gonna
work
first oh no I'm gonna ask you to draw
draw a slip of paper out of this hat
don't look at it yet just draw a piece
of paper out of this hat draw whichever
one you like whichever whichever one
feels lucky to you or good forget don't
look at it you all right okay so each of
our contestants have a piece of paper
with a name on it here's the question
vanos obviously a huge villain in the
MCU if something terrible were to happen
or let's just say Josh Brolin was
kicking back and decided not to be
Thanos who would be the best possible
person for the role to replace Thanos
let's say proactively going into in game
Bend and then going forward in the MCU
so the person on the piece of paper in
front of you is your selection for the
best possible person to replace Josh
Brolin destino so I'm gonna go to each
of you individually just say the name
and then we'll go into the arguments I'm
gonna start with Vanessa Vanessa who's
the best possible person to be the new
famous Russell Brand Russell Brand's
good choice Russell Brand's the Nomad
Titan Tony who is the best possible
person to replace an only choice okay
Dave Chappelle this spell yeah wielding
the Infinity Gauntlet and I think I have
the winner then and that is Oprah
Winfrey Oprah Winfrey already attacked
but not
now a mad tiny little bit yeah she says
she's a she's a somewhat popular
television personality so our 13 page
yeah exactly our three takes to replace
Thanos as just started to replace Josh
Brolin in the role of Thanos Dave
Chappelle Oprah Winfrey Russell Brand
Vanessa
you did see did you start first did you
go first last timer yes so ace I'm gonna
start with you you actually know Tony I
think you need to go first this time so
Tony pitch this on Dave Chappelle first
as the best possible replacement is the
new family
well we've seen him get increasingly
more dramatic roles such as he pisses
himself what is it a star is born
[Music]
yes I mean that's true you just get a
write down he pisses himself but he's
he's getting more dramatic roles and I
think you know we've seen a versatility
of range from him from the Chappelle
show and we've seen an increasingly more
leg mattock Dave Chappelle coming on and
he's is comedy special especially that
voice that he had was so engaging and
dramatic I would love to see that rasps
coming out of a Thanos and in a menacing
way the way he looks I went under
percent believe that he would be
terrifying to watch and could easily
make more dread than any of your guys
choices right full of dread Dave
Chappelle ace Oprah Winfrey I mean when
we think of fan o's we think of this
imposing powerful being oprah is already
that imposing powerful being she
embodies this sense of generosity and
and what better to show off her range as
someone having someone so tender-hearted
and so kind like oprah play the most
evil vicious god-like creature in the
world that to me is already incredible
not only does she have that incredible
voice incredible presence she already
played like a god type
in wrinkle and time Ava Duvernay movie
she has that range to really demonstrate
how her hearts can be turned towards
some sort of evil plan that's Oprah
already I feel like out of these three
she has by far the most range by far the
most experience and she knows how to
command a set and she can do that by
playing the character of Thanos she can
play this imposing powerful being
someone like Russell Brand would be
incredibly distracting and the voice
already would be incredibly annoying
Dave Chappelle would immediately take me
out of the movie but Oprah as a god I
could believe that
I could totally believe that because
again I've already seen that in wrinkle
in time I'm just seeing this evil
version of it where she's much more
playing her range and demonstrating how
powerful she can be Russell Brand I take
it a little shrapnel vennett Vanessa
before you have to defend Russell Brand
go ahead and pitch us on Russell Brand
all righty
first of all Russell Brand does have
range because if you watch his work and
either get him to the Greek or
Forgetting Sarah Marshall he can turn
his emotions on a dime and Forgetting
Sarah Marshall he can go between insane
waxing poetic rock star to someone that
just has like a dark face that just
issues like the meanest burn to someone
else we see him do this to Sarah
Marshall and we see him do this to jonah
hill with back away thank you whether
it's seaming hottie ER than someone else
which we very much see in that Thanos
type character and especially when it
comes to the gauntlet I pictured this
person like a rock star like a like a
like a rock star with a lot of like evil
dualities to them and I can see someone
with the swagger of Russell Brand
carrying that and not just that the
voice isn't good the accident itself is
very good at sounding sinister because
it there's like different movies where
he usually is playing like some kind of
like scumbag X type and he's very
cutting and we know he'll also commit to
camp because he was in Rock of Ages and
he committed to that role no matter how
goofy it was he committed to it and I
could see him doing the same thing with
a villain role because in those three
movies even though one is very goofy and
the other one he's already kind of the
villain type character he can he has the
swagger of someone
knows he can end the world with a snap
all right Chappell Winfrey brand I don't
know how you guys are gonna come to a
conclusion to the goodwitch it's and
also I will say in a wrinkle in time she
was not medicine at all she was she
wasn't that's why she amazing to see her
as but evil B III wouldn't think she
have that potential to be nor would she
want that me to be in her democratic
just simply Dave Chappelle out of these
three choices is the only guy that we
could imagine being that dark person
even in a dramatic movie even in a
comedy he can play a villain to see the
person on this he is the most likely
person here to have a deranged view of
wanting to kill half the universe or
even just kill a single person and I
think that's what makes him the better
choice she's you know Oprah's the the
older wise person she's the perch ease
the person who helps Tony Stark and all
these people we also have to imagine
these are actors replacing an actor
correct so we have to imagine the set
life of this all and I think someone
like Russell Brand would completely butt
heads with a Robert Downey jr. and a and
all the rest of those casts while we
don't need someone to be comedy we need
someone to be completely serious and he
cannot make a single joke because those
jokes are given to the characters who
are our heroes that's Tony Stark
that's Peter quill that's um even
Captain America with his language jokes
that's eat that house has to be the
straight man and Russell Brand has never
been a straight man Oprah I think is
again just she this is not her she
cannot be menacing in a wrinkle in time
she was barely in the movie and I didn't
want and even when she was 20 feet tall
in there I thought that was terrible CGI
in my opinion what if you put it behind
good CGI and good mocap because we have
to realize that Josh Brolin plays his
character perfectly I think we can all
agree on that and he doesn't play it
campy he doesn't play it over-the-top
out of the three actors that are on this
table mine is the only serious actor
these are two comedians
bro-bro is an incredible actress she has
demonstrated that time and time again
with very serious dark movies and she
that's the kind of movies she wants to
nail when she takes on a role of panels
she would take that so seriously she
would not try to riff and have fun she
would take it very seriously and take it
as a very Oscar worthy role for lack of
a better word because that's what josh
brolin is doing in this movie I feel
like Oprah would take this job seriously
she would master the mocap better than
anyone else this is the kind of role
that Oprah would want to do and to show
off her range because she is known for
being kind hearted and generous and you
know old wise person but who better than
the wise person to tell you that you're
wrong and half the universe needs to die
that's that to me is what I want to see
from an open performance that's so what
do you think about these two other
choices personally I'll say Jim Carrey
is a perfect example of somebody that's
a comedic role they can play serious
comedians play serious all the time it's
not an uncommon role Steve Carell
another perfect example I actually wrote
him down on my paper so simpatico but if
we look at a movie that was not watched
that much but it's a very good example
of somebody that can do serious the
remake of the movie Arthur starred
Russell Brand there's a scene where his
childhood nanny dies and he shows such
pathos and darkness and someone that was
deeply tortured in that scene and even
though everyone around him might be
phoning him in at certain points in
different movies he's still selling it
and he can sell dark really well like
you don't think that the frontman of
infant sorrow isn't capable of
eccentricity and also derangement I I
really like the swagger that this
character has and when I look at Dave
Chapelle and you're also looking at
onset stuff Dave is tired and like he's
a man that has worked very very hard his
career is very very choosy with what he
takes on when it comes to his time and
usually when you see him in something
he's a very very fun supporting
character because at where his career is
he's very much managing his time and his
energy and taking on something like this
is exhausting and Russell Brand he's
toured as a comedian for weeks he can
absolutely do the shooting schedule of a
Marvel movie and in the case of Oprah
she's got own to run
she would take time off to be fed she
would clearly do that I think one thing
we're missing too and then I keep
bringing it up but it's such a big
factor is that this is a motion-capture
role and vocal performance is a huge
part of it I'm sorry but these two
vocals of Dave Chappelle has a very
distinct voice and so does Russell Brand
I think Oprah's voice can embody
presence and power and dominance over
the Avengers who better than to
demonstrate I'm more powerful than you
than the vocal performance of an Oprah
so she's gonna sit down with Tony Stark
and have an interview I mean she
captures a lot of the things I mean yeah
of course you're right but the point
that you're making with my character and
her character as well
with Dave and Russell is like distinct
voices she also has a distinct voice to
know so I think all three of us in that
point have something where we're gonna
be knowing that's that person making
that one sorry I just think again like
I'm saying Dave Chappelle you're saying
she's you know he's coming in to do
supporting roles and he does them so
beautifully he that seemed that he was
in talking to Bradley Cooper the way he
did can show his range of we don't need
someone who is present completely it's a
person who can quietly get their point
across and that's what Dave Chappelle
can do even in his comedy special he
doesn't yell at the audience like a
Kevin Hart he doesn't say anything he
talks to the audience like it like
children and he tells them his point of
view and I think that would be so
beautiful to have in Thanos and you're
saying he's tired but trust me shooting
these Avengers movies and these movies
they take care of you and I will say
that having been on these sets you are
not tired at all they make sure you're
good and the money is good
so dave chappelle 100% would take this
as well as his kids would be like daddy
you don't take this imma imma imma just
not talk to you ever again so I think
again Dave Chappelle becomes becoming
Thanos not only could physically have
that kind of imposing body on set he
knows probably most of these actors he's
talked to them he has that that kind of
past life of things that he can draw
upon to have sorrow and we can see him
wanting to go to these Oscar worthy
roles more and more and we can see him
doing an amazing job at it and closing
for Thanos sorry for Dave Chappelle all
right Vanessa let's move into your
rebuttal and closing argument for
Russell Brand oh man I have a small
manifesto in here so firstly Russell
Brand is not just a actor that can play
versions of himself but he could play
other characters we see this in
Despicable Me when he actually plays a
villain a mad scientist who could do
this kind of role very well because that
man literally get away orphans in that
movie he is very much capable of an
immersive merciless snap uh he in his
actual life embodies a lot of darkness
and I feel like he could bring to the
role really well and not just that again
we want someone we want someone with
that ominous swagger and who better than
a man who willingly wears leather pants
all the time but I'm writing it down
leather pants where you have to be a
sociopath so be willing to sweat your
but that much
hashtag Russell Brand but sweat thank
you and ace your closing on Oprah
Winfrey yeah I mean I really do feel
like Oprah not only embodies that range
embodies that subtlety that we can see
from a performance Ashley has done
before an incredible performances in the
past but we're talking about you know
the ultimate evil the ultimate bad
person that the Avengers can go up
against and to have it be this epitome
of this iconic powerful woman in real
life and to embody that powerful woman
in this story it would just be an
incredible
performance and incredible opportunity
to represent things not just on a movie
scale but on a macro scale as far as
saying yes the iconic Thanos that people
make memes of and that people make
stories of and that's dancing in
fortnight is Oprah Winfrey that to me
would be a powerful moment and it would
probably give us the best performance
considering that she does take her roles
so seriously and it would be a great
opportunity to show different audiences
what Oprah can be and not just be the TV
star or the famous name but actually be
a really good actress that young people
and other generations can come to learn
about by having the iconic vanos role
all right and that is time on round
three lon before I give my judgement are
there any facts to check we mentioned
mrs. Witcher character in regular time
being a god technically they are known
as unearthly creatures not gods if you
read Madeleine L'Engle backstory they
were those three women were actually
stars that transform themselves into
humanoid characters in order to defend
the living second fact Oprah does not
sad just said to burst every wave of
Oprah does not run day to day at her
Network even though it bears her name
all right it's actually majority owned
by Discovery now not even Harpo
Productions and the current network
president is a lady named Tina Perry
theoretically have the time to make a
film all right very hard work I think
that everyone made everyone was both
dinged on and made great great hit backs
against the range argument so I feel
like the range arguments all sort of
washed out like everybody made a great
argument why their choice had the range
and the ability to play fan oohs so it
went beyond that for me and I get the
hashtag rigged things ready because I
felt like what what really got to me was
when Tony was talking about Dave
Chappelle the personality that he brings
to what he's doing now the fact that he
you know and his comedy specials he is
able to get a point across quietly that
he's able to talk to you know the
audience in a way
is unique to him I felt that that was a
good argument for the quality that he
could bring to Thanos and everyone
everyone argued really well but I was
leaning toward Tony and Dave Chappelle
but that's just my opinion lon what were
your thoughts you know I was really
leaning towards Tony and Dave Chappelle
as well I loved what he said about his
raspy dark voice I could hear it in my
head and that you know he can just go to
this sort of dark place but I don't know
Vanessa really won me over at the end
that Russell Brand he's he's given good
performances before he's brave and he I
liked what she said about Rock of Ages
that no matter how campy the material
he's gonna dedicate himself to it 100%
so I think I'm going Vanessa that's one
for Tony that's one for Vanessa Danielle
what said the people well the people in
the in the in the polls with 57% of the
vote Dave Chappelle
lots of great stuff on the movie fights
live hashtag my favorite was from our
friend get shindy who says none of these
are bad pick deez all days Russell Brand
noted political voice very heavy on
environmental issues Dave Chappelle now
grizzled and world-weary driven by one
drive most of his life Oprah the massive
cult of personality capable of
compassion while doing the necessary and
then just an aside for me we know that
Dave could get in shape because he got
super bra like when he was on break yeah
real big there we go so Tony gets the
point which means we are now activated
into our emergency tiebreaker round
here's what that means I will ask you a
question each of you will answer whoever
says the answer first that's who will
get that particular answer if there are
duplicated answers each of you will have
20 seconds to make an argument you will
each then get a ten-second rebuttal
you'll answer in the order that I hear
your answers and at the end of it we
will select the person who does not move
on to the speed round so it will be two
people move on to the speed round the
point will not carry over they will
enter the speed around tied one to one
one person will not move on to the speed
round so this is your tiebreaker
question and
I would ask you to answer after I've
finished asking the question but here is
the tiebreaker question because it
because we are we are not debating in
game today not counting Avengers in game
which is the best Russo brothers MCU
film Winter Soldier Civil War or
infinity war Civil War
infinity war Winter Soldier alright so
Tony if I'm correct Lana
Tony has civil war yeah ace you have
infinity war and Vanessa you have the
winter soldiers let me just write this
down Tony or you anyways as infinity war
vanessa has Winter Soldier and the order
that I heard the answers were going
around the table it was Tony ace Vanessa
so that's the order in which you will
give your replies Tony you will start
you have 20 seconds on the clock when
you start speaking
Civil War managed to give us so many
different characters that we didn't
think could fit into this entire
universe they gave us Black Panther and
spider-man both at the same time while
not letting them be drowned out by the
overarching fight that was Tony Stark
and Captain America and that fight
itself that dramatic tension between
them - all right ace
infinity war fully encapsulate what the
Marvel Universe brings us and it was
able to balance the characters as
far-fetched as guardians of the galaxy
with characters like Iron Man with
characters like Doctor Strange who all
have different power sets and come
together it was able to simultaneously
give us the darkest MCU movie and one of
the funniest MCU movies we've ever seen
it also give us the iconic performance
of Josh Brolin destinos who all right
Vanessa Winter Soldier
where do soldier not only raise the
stakes for us but also it introduced us
to T'Challa and it gave us a captain
that was stripped down and challenged to
have everything he knew he was out of
all of these movies what Winter Soldier
did was it didn't just tell a Marvel
story it told the story of a man who had
everything that he knew about what was
good and what was evil challenged to him
using Marvel characters so not only do
we have a Marvel story that's very well
done and forwards the story but also all
right Tony
tenseiga rebuttal
first dr. Challa was introduced in civil
war second off infinity war is a great
movie but I think Civil War set it up so
beautifully and having us the audience
be ready to have those characters mingle
all right ace a Winter Soldier has
problems with tone in the middle of the
movie and Civil War there's no real
stakes at the end we don't really lose
anyone infinity war we lose a lot of
people and if you felt those stakes and
also give us the best villain
performance in any more of a movie all
right and all right true on the Dajjal
the thing but also it drives two
challahs four story forward when it
comes to what he needs to step into when
it comes to Wakanda and not just that it
told us who the man Captain America was
going forward and how he handled things
all right
everyone did really well I think of the
two that the things that I heard most as
far as not just the movie but and the
the the the stakes what what was at
stake and how well they were executed
the most I think I heard the most from
Tony and ace so I would have to
regrettably advance my vote would be the
advance Tony an ace Vanessa I'm sorry I
would would not advance you the speed
around but there are two more opinions
left one what were your thoughts yeah I
think I agree with you once more I feel
like the Winter Soldier Civil War flung
kind of just was a big distraction and
prevented Vanessa for making sort of a
better end argument for Winter Soldier
so I think yeah I'd have to go with Tony
nice as well all right I think that
Danielle I think that that does it right
Vanessa I'm sorry that you do not
advance to the speed round Tony and ace
you both advance you are that point
because it's do not carry over so you
are tied one to one the good news is
it's still just one to one which means
it's the best of four games so you both
have a lot of opportunity to advance
there's gonna be a long speed round so
let's get right into it
question number one the rules are the
same I will ask a question the person I
hear first will answer first give their
answer first you'll have 20 seconds with
a ten second rebuttal and here is your
first question
again none of these are inclusive of
adventures in game or anything happens
yes Tony or spider-man far from home for
that matter all right
question one what is the best mid or
post credit scene from an MCU film Nick
Fury at the end of Ironman patience
Captain America spider-man homecoming oh
the the so Iron Man the kids
demonstrated videos right Ironman
recruiting at the end of a hired man
correct Ninja Theory and the captain
record PSA at the end of Spider Man
homecoming at Ace you answered first so
he wins we've seen Hollywood so many
times try to copy a cinematic universe
and this was the one that did it it
introduced a new character to us that
teased a possible opportunity to make a
gigantic universe of movies that fully
embody the Avengers initiative that
started with samuel l.jackson an
incredible actor playing Nick Fury
coming into the end of the movie to join
in with Iron Man someone who already
became iconic with just one movie Tony
I think we're the eighteenth movie in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe homecoming
and having that patient seen being at
the end you know saying hey man you
could wait for something and maybe
nothing happens is it calculates how far
we come and saying you know what maybe
you got something maybe you didn't but
either way we're here and we love you
and I think that's what's so great that
you set it up we're the first one and
this is kind of it attack is what I love
about MCU mid-credits scenes are teasing
what's to come none better does that the
Nick Fury unfortunately the patients one
was funny but it didn't ease anything
that we can see in future Marvel movies
this is the one that set all the other
ones up alright Tony we don't need
anything to be set up anymore because we
know these characters you know these
comic books and we're just ready for the
next thing and whether they tease or not
we're going to the movie so that doesn't
do anything anymore that's my opinion
and I think alright this is really close
because I think you both had a really
unique perspective on it as far as
influential versus something rewarding
the fans for it I think I'm gonna give a
slight edge to Ace I think but it's very
very close lon what do you think I
leaned the opposite way it was close
great arguments for both but I thought I
really like Tony's argument that we've
gotten to know these characters we don't
need to be teased anymore just give us
something fun give us another character
beat with them I also love that scene
with Captain Burke at the end of
homecoming so I'm gonna tell me Daniel
you're in the favorite position you get
to be the tiebreaker what do you think
yeah me yeah so I got you you're right
both of these were really really
difficult so this is gonna come by like
a hair
I really appreciated hmm
I'm still making up my mind as I'm
talking about isn't it it's the
difference between again it's is it
about the tease or is it about a filmy
familiarity with the material and maybe
subverting expectations I like what Tony
had to say about it so bringing the
expectation and showing that we don't
necessarily need to see too much it's an
argument I think a lot of us have made
where it's like hey we don't need to see
a whole lot we're already and on these
movies I'm going with Tony okay
Tony takes a 2-1 lead going into
question 2
what is a what is the better part 3 MCU
film Thor Ragnarok or Captain America's
Civil War Thor Ragnarok alright SS Thor
Ragnarok Tony that leaves you with the
civil war issue answered first so you
will talk first what I will tackle YTD
delivered in Thor Ragnarok was bringing
a new rebirth of this character it
introduced Thor in a different light in
a different manner what he was able to
flex his comedy muscles and be unique
and be different
we were also introduced to new funny
characters like Valkyrie like Korg these
characters that were enabled to interact
with Thor in a different manner it also
gave us the best relationship between
Thor and Loki alright Tony
Civil War again brought us so many new
characters bring it brought in we got a
great set up to infinity war with the
Captain America and Tony Stark being
broken Thor Ragnarok is funny and it's
great and it's a great piece for the
Thor but Civil War is great for the
whole of MCU and it sets up so many
different things we have so many
different cool moments a sense that Robo
at time Civil War didn't know what
character I was dealing with whether was
Iron Man or Captain America I knew this
was stores movie all the way in and had
fun interactions with Hulk to me this
defined different tones that Marvel can
do not knowing which the characters just
goes to show that they gave them equal
footing and the writing is that
incredible that you didn't know who
should have that lead moment and you
were going back and forth between which
character you sided with alright one I'm
gonna abdicate the first way to you
because it annoys me when when I it has
it's done to me because I usually have
to have my mind made up both both cool
movies both really good arguments I
thought ace had a sort of slight edge if
you shout out Korg in your argument I'm
already kind of on
he gave us more about you know the
specifics of Ragnarok and why that
worked as opposed to more so I'm going
with ace ace and the Korg obviously the
the takeaway here a Korg dimension never
a bad idea yeah Danyelle see both kind
of quarks yes cats displayed over score
yeah like score gives long likes Korg
Daniel what you think I got to agree
with lon I think that in that one may
he's definitely had although again both
both great and I loved what you had to
say about Civil War and how it was great
for setting up the rest of the MCU but
yeah aces arguments were really really
specific so all right ace gets the point
so it is now tied to two Tony and ace
both two points away from the win
here's the next question mm-hmm oh it's
a heartbreaker are you ready for this
one right who's the better guardian Drax
or rocket Drex rocket all right I love
the confidence yeah
ace I get once again I heard you you
said Jax first so you speak first 20
seconds dave bautista was a revelation
in this movie guardians of the galaxy it
not only made him a movie star it showed
us the destroyed man in this crazy cast
of characters his different style of
comedy was so different from someone
like a Peter Coyle or a rocket or a
Groot that is the most different funny
dynamic character we get out of
guardians of the galaxy and that comes
straight from Dave Batista's performance
all right Tony
purely on vocal performance from Bradley
Cooper making us both laugh and cry when
he's hugging Groot as Groot says I am
Groot
which by the way the director said he's
actually saying dad goes to show how how
much heart that character has and how we
come to love a furry little rock a
raccoon and all the different yeah if we
want to have iconic lines
why is Gamora him eating the chips in
the middle of a crazy scene all the
funniest moments we can think of an
infinity war in guardians of the galaxy
to his interactions were mantis were the
best part of the movie David he says
supporting rocket can have his own arc
we've seen it in both guardians movies
him falling in love with
family and saying and and having this
this loner person having this become his
family alright Danielle I'm gonna go to
you first oh you know what they were
neck-and-neck right up until Tony took
the lead for me when he mentioned and
not only you know we've got a lot of the
really funny stuff with Big Dave Batista
but the fact that rocket had does have
such a huge character erk1 that over for
me
alright so that's one vote for tone
sorry for yeah for Tony I think that I
thought that was a great closing but I
actually would lean more toward ace I
just think that the way that he did the
the argument for the distinction of
himself the distinctive personality the
fact that he is he does sort of stand
alone as far as his his inherent
qualities and traits I think that was a
really strong argument so I go toward
ace that's one two one one what's the
high breaker I know it's very hard I
love both these characters I thought
both of these arguments were really good
sort of went back and forth for me but
you know ultimately I thought what Tony
said about rocket has arcs and his
character really sort of progresses
whereas Drax kind of comes in and says
funny things but he's ultimately the
same as when we first met and that
really resonated for me something gonna
go Tony Tony
alright so Tony picks up a 3-2 lead Tony
this is game point for you ace you can
stay in and force it to a final question
if you win this point here's the
question oh this is an easy one now you
have to specify not just the actor but
also the specific film who gives the
best single performance in an MCU film
I'm gonna say Robert Downey jr. is civil
war ever done in Junior Civil War okay
Tony you could say yourself it's gonna
bite me in the ass but screw it ya Flash
Thompson
[Applause]
Your Honor Spencer Tony why not go down
and who knows in a movie filled with
heart and emotions in politics and and
death and family Robert Downey jr.
delivers the craziest performance by
giving us the realization of someone who
killed their mom and seeing that happen
on screen not only breaks the audience's
heart but it breaks your heart for Tony
and it makes you side with Tony Stark
even though cat might have the right
ideals the heart of Tony Stark is what
sells it all right Tony tell me about
Tony I'll first say that I think the
performance of Robert Downey jr. is
better and infinity when we see him as a
father figure and and and dealing with
everything you said but times 10 in that
movie and why Flash Thompson is the best
single performance and an MCU film
because we see a new character that has
been old updated in a new kind of way
and updated with the social media
bullying
I absolutely agree Flash Thompson is
updated however the better performance
and the one who has more movies and more
screen time to do that is a civil war
and we see the culmination of Robert
Downey jr. bring the character full
circle all right and Tony
you have a sag ensemble nominee Antonio
Flash Thompson the 6-2 blonde blue eyes
and still having all the menace and all
the the bullying that we see in the
comics Wow I thought it I thought Tony
was just having fun too I think that may
have been a very strong strategic move
because I didn't really hear anything
negative about the performance and
picture of the character the fact that
it is a it is a bully who is still has
the same kind of Menace and those are
really good arguments you ready for that
Tony Tony Tony I think I gotta go with
Tony uh Danielle wood what do you think
you know this is a cipher mom I I
actually didn't know that the actor was
a second son woman and that's my bad I
didn't do my research I should fact
check it but that's fine um
honestly for me it was with it was when
Tony mentioned he had a really good
comeback about how Robert Downey jr. is
great in civil war but we get to see
more from him an infinity war with how
he is a founder father figure to Peter
and handsome and that was a great
argument and I didn't really hear
[Applause]
it's declared well here first folks you
sing this later we had this we had to
re-upload this because we couldn't
stream this live I wish we could have
streamed this live to see when people
said Tony I would ask where can people
find you but this article it's up right
now on Famicom whose links on my
Instagram and Twitter and spider-man
farm opens July 2nd Road 3rd July 3rd
yes you can see spider-man far from home
their home far from home yes spider-man
far from home II I apologize
pronunciation right H Cabrera thank you
for coming a hard fought soon around try
to find you you can find me on twitter
and instagram at squad leader race and
also check out the meaning of podcast on
the first cut youtube channel and also
on collider factory the itunes feed
awesome and vanessa griten you got agent
maria hill inducted into the avengers so
you do not walk away in that was all I
wanted going in it was like if I have
that one I'm happy there you go
so a we have a new Avenger yeah we're at
where else can people you can find me on
Twitter and all forms of social media
under a desk written and also check out
my sketch team we do films on link
sketches on horror and cult based movies
which is real fun and it's under night
Church so find us it's why I've
developed a taste for fake blood I'm
awesome
there we go live day in college or on
the couch that's the thing you guys want
to call out
that was that I am still that was
fantastic
yeah if you like wrestling I've got my
wrestling podcast tights and fights it
comes up every Thursday I've been
writing the honest trailer so we're
hoping to write so if you guys like
seeing me do more things I've been doing
them and you a team more new dresses
soon you guys I promise and also Vanessa
didn't mention this so I'm gonna do it
for her she is going to be on a show
it's been announced yeah Ellery nation
on the Ellery network probably mentions
the TV thing yeah I know it's just cuz
I'm not sure how much I can what I'm
allowed to say god I'd like hit boy i am
i showing this is the show Tony you're
kind of the same boat yeah thank you
guys for joining us forever being the
voice of the people were keeping our
facts straight thank you to Billy
business Jost are helping produce the
show TT buying the board Ryan everyone
helping us on the socials and the
streams now we will be back next week
with an all new movie fight so we make
sure that I'm not forgetting anything
that I need to plug no that's pretty
much it
thanks for joining us how run dick we'll
return next week we have another cool
panel coming up and the Somoza more cool
stuff coming up in the future until next
time thanks for watching
[Music]
you